do you have any thoughts on the
existence of free will
do you think you have free will and if
not then why not if so why so
how are you defining it i thought about
this a bit and what i
eventually came to the conclusion was
that i didn't even know how to define
what free will was
so if you can't define something
precisely it makes it very hard to
discuss
in fact this this is a big problem with
an awful lot of philosophical questions
if you look at them close enough you
discover the terms in them are simply
not well defined enough to talk about
so can you even define free will can you
talk about it not as a mathematician but
let's say as a regular person about what
free will
about free will now what you're saying
is that there's the slippery definition
but so
there is also a slippery definition as
to what constitutes a chair
or i or you and presumably you've used
those in sentences before
with facility well that so can you do
this yeah i i can sort of
vaguely define a chair in some way that
i can most the time recognize a chair
i've
i've tried to define free will and i
just cannot come up with a definition i
poached around a bit and as far as i can
figure out nobody else has come up with
a convincing definition either
i mean you certainly have this feeling
in inside yourself
that you can choose what to do but
um you know maybe this feeling is an
illusion
and everything we do is determined by
some laws of physics and we just have
this illusion that
we're choosing what these laws of
physics do
but i don't know i mean i i can't even
define what is meant by
having a feeling that we we can choose
what to do
so you're agnostic on the issue i'm
i think it's even worse than being
agnostic i i'd say i i don't
i'm not saying i don't know what the
answer the question is i'm saying i
i don't even know what the question
means and i'm not at all sure it even
makes sense
what about god do you believe in god and
the same problem
uh before we start discussing god i
would like you to define what you mean
by the term
god because there are so many different
definitions
um so you could have a god of your
favorite religion saying it's this
guy who maybe zaps people with
thunderbolts or whatever
or you could say you know god is just a
name
for the underlying essence of the
universe which is sort of
maybe meaningless but you could say in
in that sense god exists because it's
god is just a name for whatever the
explanation of the universe is so there
are
all these different possible definitions
of god and
some of them that you
you could recently say they do exist
some of them you could say
there seems to be very little evidence
for it and others it's just not clear
what the question means so
before discussing this philosophical
question let's first have some
precise definitions you mentioned one
that god is the universe in some way
shape or form
now why is that meaningless well it
because
it's just words it doesn't actually tell
you anything more about the universe
that you didn't already know
um so that there's a whole lot of
questions like this you could say you
know the
the universe is really a simulation or
the universe is um a cellular automaton
or maybe there are lots of parallel
universes
and none of these actually say anything
whatsoever about the universe i mean
that they're all
great plots for comic book stories or
whatever but
you know what what's the difference
between the universe being a cellular
automata and the universe not being a
cellular automaton well i've
there just doesn't seem to be any
difference or what what's the universe
what's the difference between there
being a sort of pantheistic god
underlying everything or they're not
being a pantheistic god well
i've no idea it it just seems to be a
content free
sentence in your psychology and your
mindset nothing would be changed if you
found out that you were the only
conscious person or that you were living
in a dream
i i don't know how i could tell the
difference between being the only
conscious person or not being the only
conscious person
i mean i assume other people are
conscious just by analogy with myself
but i
i can't imagine any experiment that
could actually prove beyond doubt that
someone else was really conscious rather
than just a
rather than just a computer program
running inside someone's brain
okay again it's this problem of what is
free will i
i can't think of any experiment that can
tell the difference between having free
will and not having free will
okay how about this i imagine that there
is no experiment that can test
whether you love your wife or your wife
loves you yet i
imagine also that the answer to that
matters to you
so in a similar well does it first of
all well it's it's a it's another these
terms it's really hard to
define i mean i'm i think this is this
is another question about my internal
state of mind which as i've noticed in
several of your other questions i a very
hard time figuring out what my internal
state of mind actually
is is that because you're not
introspective
do you tend to think about yourself or
do you just tend to think outside
yourself
i i do sometimes think about myself and
the conclusion i tend to come to is that
i have absolutely no idea what is going
on i mean it's it's
it's a problem that i've that completely
baffles me
i mean i've no idea what is going on in
my own mind let alone what is going on
in other people's minds